se acerca el final del caso que enfrenta
la ex pareja de actores johnny depp y
hombre a quien él denunció por
difamación por un valor de 50 millones
de dólares a finales de 2018 la actriz
dijo en la prensa a ser una víctima de
violencias conyugales aunque no mencionó
a depp el rechazo claras referencias a
su relación no vimos ningún ser humano
es perfecto ciertamente ninguno de
nosotros pero nunca en mi vida he
cometido agresión sexual abuso físico
todas estas historias son extravagantes
y escandalosas
durante seis semanas los abogados
llamaron al estado a los artistas así
como a expertos y testigos que hablaron
de la intimidad del matrimonio que duró
entre 2015 y 2017 retrataron una
relación tóxica entre las pruebas hay
fotos de la droga consumida por johnny
depp y que dan cuenta de su adicción al
alcohol que según la actriz lo volvieron
violento en caridad de denunciada
amberger también atacó a su ex esposo y
lo culpa de mundo por 100 millones de
dólares declaró con imágenes que fue
golpeada por él
era el amor de mi vida y lo era pero
también era esta otra cosa y la otra
cosa fue horrible
afirmó además que fue violada lo que
denegó evocando por el contrario una
pelea que le dejó con un dedo
parcialmente mutilado supuestamente
porque ella le arrojó una botella
la señora hertz en su frustración y en
su rabia en su cólera ella golpearía
ella podía empezar con una bofetada
podía empezar con un en polvo
de lo que se trata esta conversación es
la disparidad la disparidad entre johnny
y yo en nuestras peleas físicas la
disparidad de como él me golpeaba
proactivamente y yo tenía que recurrir a
golpearlo reactivamente reactive hearing
mientras se emite una sentencia sus
carreras están en pausa y ambos alegan
pérdidas millonarias mientras se espera
que este proceso marque un precedente en
violencia doméstica